Welcome back everyone this is going to be my
new thor loving thunder trailer video marvel
has a bunch of easter eggs and there were a
bunch of questions that you had on my trailer
video yesterday so i'll try to answer those during
this especially the biggest ones if you're brand
new to the channel be sure to subscribe to get
all the videos there's a bunch of thor footage
that we're going to be getting pretty soon because
doctor strange 2 is about to come out in theaters
for those of you asking about the timeline where's
doctor strange when this is all happening the
events of doctor strange 2 are supposed to take
place around the time that this is happening
there's an easter egg for what's happening in
thor love and thunder during spiderman no way
home at the beginning of the movie one of jay
jonah jameson's broadcast is talking on the
ticker about strife happening in new asgard and
that's what you're seeing during the trailer so
that's why doctor strange just doesn't pop over
and help out with gore the godbutcher because
he's dealing with all these crazy multiverse level
problems when the events of thor love and thunder
are taking place but answering some of the biggest
questions that i saw on my trailer video yesterday
a lot of you are asking about what is going on
with thor's two blue eyes during the trailer
because technically the last we saw him during
avengers infinity war in avengers end game one of
the eyes was cybernetic and it was brown so they
were mismatched eyes if you notice he does have
the scar over one of his eyes that's where he lost
the eye that's where the cybernetic one should be
the whole thing with him having two blue eyes
during this and the fact that they look the same
is you have to remember that it's a cybernetic eye
they can make it look like whatever they wanted
to look like so he probably just decided that he
wanted two blue eyes some of the producers and the
people that worked on the film have also confirmed
some of the details from the trail that we were
confused about yesterday too like what's going on
when they go to mount olympus there's a big statue
of zeus in the background with his lightning
bolt you see tiny little figure of thor here
talking to their delegation there are actually two
red capes so that means that by the time they go
there he's already seen jane foster thor she's
already gotten the hammer and they've already
figured out what's going on with gore and they're
trying to pursue him a lot of you have also asked
because thor's wearing so many different new
versions of costumes during the trailer there
are like three or four different new costumes
for him when he's wearing the construction
worker ravagers uniform that's designed on the
eric masterson thunderstrike costume a lot of
you are asking is the belt because it's a new
belt buckle new belt pretty much all new clothes
all of them are designed to be big classic easter
eggs for the original thor comics does that mean
that the belt that he's wearing is the actual belt
from spider-man homecoming that happy mention his
special belt that's meant to double his strength
that he just left over at the avengers base it's
always possible that that is the special belt but
i don't think that's the case i think it's just
custom clothing that he had made when he was with
the ravagers like this is all clothing that peter
quill would have had access to as well when he had
some of this made he probably just had some of it
made custom so that it had asgardian designs
and easter eggs built into it like when he's
doing the workout montage losing all that weight
and you see him wearing the custom avengers hat
it's the avengers logo from the original avengers
comics and it's the same colors too like someone
literally copy pasted the logo and the design the
colors from that original comic book cover except
he asked them to make it custom to say strongest
avenger just to help pump himself up in a big call
back to thor ragnarok when iron man left that joke
for him to access the quinjets this will also get
into the whole idea of where they're taking
thor in the mcu because now we have a second
version of thor with jane foster what does this
mean for the future of chris hemsworth's thor in
the future of the avengers movies marvel phase
5 whatever going forward i need to figure out
exactly who i am this gets into more
rune king thor and more of his cosmic
responsibility becoming more of a true god of
the mcu just like odin became a god of the mcu
this ties into what we're learning about on moon
knight episodes right now too with the legit gods
of the mcu and how they're different from just
the really powerful cosmic beings of the mcu best
example that are the celestials like star-lord for
example has half-celestial dna because of ego the
living planet he's kind of like a rogue celestial
but the celestials as they explain are not actual
legit gods they're just really really powerful
cosmic beings the whole idea with odin is that
he was not born a god in the mcu he was just born
a really powerful cosmic being as part of his race
tying things back to real-life norse mythology the
whole idea with odin becoming a god attaining the
odin force is about him going through all
these trials that they spell it in classic
norse mythology and while that was happening he
gained the true faith of his followers and that
sort of minted him a legit god in the mcu so all
that extra power came later he wasn't born with
all that power but once he did become a legit god
in the mcu like all legit mcu gods he was able to
biologically have children and pass that god tier
power onto his children hella in thor it's the
same for all the other pantheons of gods around
the mcu khonshu on moon knight for example is the
biological sister of boss the panther goddess and
they're meant to be the children of a tongue the
leader of their egyptian pantheon who is sort of
like their version of raw the sun god but one of
the big themes of the trailer is thor shirking his
responsibilities kind of going back to ground with
the world tree or the version of the world
tree this is kind of what this is meant to
inspire thinking about his life and what he needs
to be doing with himself what he should be doing
as people who've read the comics we obviously know
he has a greater cosmic responsibility like there
are way bigger threats out there that he should
be dealing with using all this cosmic power for
we're just witnessing him come to that realization
through the course of the movie and gore the god
butcher is going to be the catalyst that causes
him to do that like the way that god should be
helping their subjects because the whole thing
with gore the god butcher is that he's going
around slaughtering all the gods of the mcu
because he says that they're selfish and he's
not wrong let me remind you should we part you
may not like my next candidate near and dear as
she is to you you've seen the way that khonshu
acts during the moon knight series he's very
capricious he doesn't really care about human life
that much even though he wants justice he doesn't
really care about the well-being of his subjects
it's the same for most of the other gods of the
mcu and that's why gore going around killing
all of them actually isn't that bad of a thing
they'll get into this during the moon knight
series too when you kill a god it's possible
for their essence to survive like when odin died
during thor ragnarok you see the odin force's
essence sort of transferred itself to their
version of valhalla which for asgardians in the
mcu is kind of like an alternate dimension so just
because their earthly body dies doesn't mean that
their essence dies too but the thing with gore the
god butcher is that he uses the necro sword to be
able to perma-kill mcu gods and that's why they're
really afraid of him like he'd want to go after
all the other gods that are part of conscious
pantheon so even though they're in the overvoid
this pocket dimension hiding out from the rest of
the third dimension of the mcu where most of our
time is spent gore would still be able to use his
power through the necro sword and the other cosmic
power he attains along the way to go kill them
in this alternate dimension as he continues to
kill more and more people he finds new and new
cosmic power to find ways to get the other gods
that are even more powerful that's why during the
gore storyline in the comics there were actually
multiple versions of thor from his own timeline
that had to team up to defeat gore there were
three different versions there was like a young
version of thor from really early in his timeline
there was the present-day version of thor who
wielded his axe and then there was the old man
thor version after he become king thor for a long
time it looked more like odin he'd lost an eye
he'd lost his arm and replaced it with the arm of
the destroyer so anytime you see this this is like
old man thor during marvel phase 4 multiverse is
a big concept we're seeing variants of a bunch of
these big characters issues that during thor love
and thunder they're combining with the mighty thor
arc so instead of doing multiple thors from
across his own timeline they're doing multiple
thors using the jane foster version of thor the
whole idea being that gore is too powerful for
one version of thor as he is as you see him but
the easter egg that you probably noticed is it the
first time that he learns about jane foster thor
he's wearing the old version of the costume but in
the footage where he's using stormbreaker in the
bifrost to travel in the goat boat and when he's
high-fiving cork he's wearing the new rune king
thor looking version the costume that's blue and
gold so i talked about how odin became a god in
the mcu like he went through all these trials that
are based on classic norse mythology thor winds
up doing the same thing he decides is this power
enough for me or do i need more so they have
a version of what you saw at the end of thor
ragnarok except in the comics it was the presence
of the odin force who sort of presented itself in
the form of this small child and basically told
thor how to complete all these trials and take
it way further than odin took it but in doing so
attain even more power than odin ever obtained
and that's how thor became rune king thor the most
powerful version of thor like crazy powerful in
fact after this in the comics the reason why
you don't see rune king thor pop up so much
is because he was so powerful it was kind of hard
for the writers to fit him into story so they had
to find a way to de-power him i think they have
something similar planned for chris hemsworth thor
in the future of the mcu a way to explain how he's
not around for earth-based problems all the time
but he's still around just in general they'll give
him a huge rune king thor style power up but as
part of that big power up he'll realize he has a
greater cosmic responsibility and just spend most
of his time traveling around the universe solving
really big problems in what they'll do for a lot
of these smaller earth-based problems they'll
use the jane foster version of thor in the future
a lot of you also asked about the guardians of
the galaxy where's rocket what's going on with
their characters now in the timeline because
we have guardians of the galaxy 3 that they're
finishing up right now there is a guardian's
holiday special that's going to be airing this
december it'll be like a christmas special one-off
but it'll be set up for guardians 3 so it will be
required watching it'll be live action but it'll
be based on the classic star wars holiday special
right now they have not encountered adam warlock
yet so it's not like he's hidden in any of this
footage anywhere remember he's basically following
his original comic story the sovereign are
creating him to destroy the guardians but he'll
pull a vision during the course of that movie
where he comes to his incredible cosmic senses
that the guardians are not as evil as he was told
and he winds up siding with them you notice the
groot is still teenage groot size they're probably
gonna save him growing to alpha groot size like
full adult groot for guardians three it feels like
he would say something that big for that movie
there is another comic book easter egg that i
didn't point out in my video too when thor is sort
of narrating about his life like he's thinking to
himself about what he's going to be doing in the
future and he's with korg they're standing on the
mountaintop in that frozen wasteland with a giant
rat creature that's frozen over in ice that's
taken directly out of the gore of the god butcher
storyline one of the funny things they don't show
you in the trailer is because all this tourism now
is happening inside new asgard like valkyrie wants
the town to be able to earn money you see this
kind of united nations situation going on with
all these other world leaders meeting with her
inside the halls of new asgard as part of all this
they also have another fake play like the one that
loki engineered during thor ragnarok except this
fake play is based on the events of thor ragnarok
because the idea is that all the fake plays play
on the events of the previous movie kind of
making fun of it matt damon came back to play fake
loki luke hemsworth chris hemsworth's real life
brother came back to play the fake version of thor
and they have melissa mccarthy playing a fake
version of hella to sort of replay the events
of odin's death and the breaking of mjolnir that's
also probably there to sort of set up jane foster
getting the hammer too like you see a fake funny
version of the hammer being broken but then it
reforms for actual jane foster but if there
any other big questions that i didn't address
during this video or easter eggs that you noticed
that i didn't talk about in my last couple of
videos just post them in the comments below i'll
do more thor videos as we learn more connections
with moon knight and what's going on with the
legit gods of the mcu my full moon knight episode
4 video will post next it's going to be crazy so
make sure you enable orders for my channel so you
don't miss that everyone click here for my other
really big thor love and thunder trailer video
and click here for my moon knight episode 4 video
i'll update the link as soon as i post that video
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!